playwatch listen is supported by patreon
who actually got this episode unedited
early and AD free if you want to support
the podcast check the link in the
description we are going to have
uh Troy and Austin join us today when
they can but I actually had a question
that I've been meaning to ask you
specifically that I was like will I ever
get to ask this question you can never
really plan anything for this show
um this is based on a Twitter thread
from a friend who is a programmer I
wanted to pose you the question
which do you think is harder writing or
programming
it's an incredibly unfair question as
someone who works with both writers
that's why I'm asking you
face the people that you work with I'm
asking you to base it on you yourself
because I do both correct
I I think it's definitely different
parts of the brain like I think which
may is what makes it hard it's not so
much like it's politically difficult to
answer it's more like witches harder
going to the gym or cooking an amazing
meal like they're kind of it's so
separate and so different by the way
it's going to the gym
um it's so it's so like because because
writing is
uh they're both creative but I would say
writing is a world of no right answers
whereas programming is a world one
sounds like an objectively correct
answer
yeah but then there's different design
patterns and methodologies in
programming so like I think a good
programs
no because the latest Artistry to how
you code something they're absolutely
right but I think I think with writing
of whatever is being discussed at this
moment I guess it's less specific about
its objectives no you're going into the
process and you're going hey yeah how's
it going you're going into the process
and you're going I my role here is to
tell a good story whereas a programmer
generally their role is to make
something work so I disagree heartily
Austin I post Mike the question uh which
is harder writing or programming
obviously composing music
definitely composing music definitely
composing music
but I decided to come in Swinging with
no regard for the existing conversation
welcome dates my rifle welcome I think I
think any sufficiently like high tier
skill and I would say writing
programming and composing are all in
that category balances like a mechanical
execution element and a creative element
I would say I would say that
um an excellent programmer has a better
sense at the start of a process what
they should do than an excellent writer
would have so I think that that
differentiates it
um and I'm neither like but I think I
think those the top of either tier Woods
would
it would be clearer to a program or the
solution to the problem was yeah do you
it's also it's yeah it's mitigated by
the fact that games programming is a
very specific kind of programming as
well right we're not talking about like
so it's game trading fintech all the
Sciences yeah yeah exactly exactly
compared to every other kind of writing
is that um it would seem to me that uh
maybe kind of that's what you're hinting
at about the idea of it of the
specialization of games programming but
it would seem to me
from just the looking over the fence
that I've done on on projects and laying
no expertise to how to do either of
those tasks that
you can kind of skirt by with functional
code because often it's like does this
perform
you know exactly what's needed and
nothing more because we have a hundred
other fires to put out whereas writing
that just barely gets by
is more glaringly obvious and harder to
sort of hide or live with I feel like
there's some some games you play I think
they're managing quite well with the
scouting part well it's a lot of them
but I do think people notice but we're
extremely aware that's true yeah yeah
that's the that's the joke that's that's
the joke answer I have because every
time there's a new console I do an
interview and I'm asked like what what
exciting new things does PlayStation 5
open up to you as a developer it's like
I can be a slightly worse programmer
because I could be less efficient I can
be Messier with my stuff because I have
all the Headroom AAA is bumping their
head against that Headroom so they have
to like be very talented and skilled but
the higher that ceiling is the easier it
is for Indie so we're never gonna like
absolutely fully exploit the hardware it
makes it easier for us to be a bit
sloppy to that end ultimately is the
reality of making anything and releasing
it you know you have to make compromises
I saw Angela share uh a thing I assume
this is true it feels very plausible but
I have no clue if it's actually true but
they but she shared a thing on Instagram
that made me laugh regarding Maggie
Robertson's Lady of dimitreska said that
there were more polygons in her
character's ass than the entirety of the
first Resident Evil
I don't believe that well it depends it
depends if you're talking about the high
poly bank if you're talking about like
the Zed brush ass that was later baked
down into a low poly ass that might be
that might be welcome Troy but once
we're talking about in-game house
there's no way Patrick slide up to that
okay let me let me uh let me talk about
jumping into the deep end good God pass
the defense right in the crevice yeah um
so the the person who wrote the thread
is uh Christina who goes by
um hi Christina chopsky on
um Twitter and
she do we like Christina
also has experience in book programming
and writing and argued that she thinks
that programming is significantly easier
than writing
um interesting for the reason posting
I've always been a bit more diplomatic I
I can't program I have no it would be
insane for me to have an opinion I don't
know but she was like it's a thing I'm a
programmer it's a thing that you can no
you're a scientist you have an answer
too you can write something that you
think is brilliant and and it can still
at the end of the day resonate with
nobody which makes it bad writing which
doesn't necessarily happen with
programming I just thought it was a
super interesting question I'd never
seen anybody raise before I at my own
Peril jump into this conversation having
absolutely no idea what you guys talking
about but there is some great I think
I've mentioned these before some great
um talks that Rod Serling who I still
think is one of the greatest American
Writers
um
second Road selling reference I've heard
today carry on all right you should come
up in conversation a lot today man it's
so worth a deep dive he did these two
talks at USC
um one at the uh at the end of Twilight
Zone
um right right before Night Gallery was
was about to to go on and but he talks
about
somebody asks him you know are you who
are you writing for are you writing for
the audience or are you writing for
yourself and he the way that he answers
it is is pretty compelling because it is
a little bit of both
but at the end of the day I I think as
long as I'm just in the middle of this
great podcast with um with Rick Rubin
and he just reinforces the notion that
we it's it's a huberman lab with Andrew
humerman who's a he's a scientist
um legitimate at Stanford but he has
this three hour podcast with a brick
Ruben and
one of the most creative minds most
successful producers in music and
someone who's still to this day I kick
myself and it shows my arrogance and my
Prejudice and just terrible I was at a
Premiere not having a Premiere screening
of the doors and there was this guy
sitting behind I think I've told the
story before there's a guy sitting
behind me I was like they let a homeless
man into
this I mean he looks the I mean he's
screened it that guy has a mighty beard
a mighty beard and just wears nothing
like he's just it was just like a dirty
t-shirt or whatever wearing nothing and
I went outside to smoke and he was
outside in the lobby there's nobody else
with the man's Chinese Theaters nobody
else just he and I and I was like this
who allowed this and it is to this day
it's one of those things where I'm like
that's black mark on your your on your
character
yeah when you meet Tony
[Laughter]
anyway let's do pull yourself out for it
oh man on the daily when I listen to
this and he'll never know he'll never
know
listen fan yeah
it's also probably far from the first
time that's happened to him true like he
probably he probably he's sort of
misassed a lot he couldn't with a Brit
with a box of fiber couldn't give two
[__] it's I mean just that's that's
someone who is just so beyond that's
quite the uh description yeah but it's a
good description of the Texas phrase hi
everybody Austin did you find out if
what you said is true
um I found the source of it I I had
originally just seen an image but it's
it's uh I'm pretty certain that this was
like it was marveling at the high poly
count and it was stated as a like
there's practically more polygons in her
ass than so it was less of a statement
is this Christina we're talking about
this is a um no someone was saying that
lady d from Resident Evil 8 uh had more
polygons than her ass than the entirety
of the first game uh and I see looking
at it again actually Googling from the
first alone in the dark I could believe
it alone in the dark like that was five
Follies through the source in our little
and our little Hangout chat here one two
let's count on me about it three I'll be
up for a carry on
um I just watched something happened in
you last night because I really want to
watch it oh that's good oh oh so I'm not
the last one I haven't seen it yet I
still have it
oh you two just cover your ass man try
to talk about it oh my God my Bissell
it's so
spider is still uh to me one of Ray
finds best performances if you've never
seen it it's this is the Cronenberg
movie Yes incredibly dark who is the
composer Howard Shore he did that in God
he did that in between fellowship and
two towers that was what was so
interesting is that it was a little
intimate string quartet and clarinet
score in between the first two Lord of
the Rings films
you bet you come for the king you best
not miss no [__]
there's pretty much one good guess with
Spielberg
Hans Zimmer yes okay uh it's incredibly
dark disturbing movie that Josephine
sorry uh has uh uh just this incredibly
subdued performance but I think this
might be his best performance I really
think he might get has he been nominated
I don't even know if the minion they got
all different Buzz I've announced them
yet it was on HBO so I don't know if it
ever did any screens there's a slow burn
I don't know I knew from the onset I
didn't know anything about it but I knew
from the onset what what what the what
the thing was advertises itself is a far
more stupid movie than it is which I
find a little careful I'm expecting it
to be
um like a little bit thrillery and a
dark comedy yes
yeah I think both of those things are
true definitely leaning more into the
Thriller I think I expect there's a
yeah there's a there's a bit of a lie
going on in the trailer this version of
the trailer that came out over here
we could talk about trailers yeah that
pinged a thing I meant to bring up here
uh previously I'm gonna I'm gonna pivot
away since I haven't watched this movie
but it is related to what you just said
did you see our conversations are like a
90s
I've never seen RR
you have to Megan oh no the new uh I
thought you had a stroke what are you
talking about it's RR why are you saying
all like that point Oscar because I'm
Oscar water why would you say oh
[Laughter]
I think this might be the worst episode
we've ever had Austin go ahead
no we have to join us
and it's a callback oh [__]
eat that Spotify listeners
amazing are you gonna do yours too go
yes [__] mine's downstairs
or as we thought both of us thought we
were like we would read the book Oscar
water awesome I do appreciate that both
of us sought Redemption by buying the
book immediately I think neither of us
have read it yet by the way if you're
not familiar with him he's a great actor
um he uh he posted something about the
uh I'm gonna say it wrong komogatu or um
we were talking about last episode what
the kobayashimaru is based on oh yeah
what are the uh correct me I want to
make sure that I'm saying all right what
is it called the code
or something forgive me I'm not saying
correctly I was just I found it
interesting he just posted that it was
like it was the anniversary of it but he
just happened to
to mention it I was like we must be Tom
Aaron
does anyone know what that means no it
was actually nerdy for this show that's
too too many no nothing's too
no no no no [__] you have to what I
said Tom Aaron Tav Aaron it's not like a
Game of Thrones thing no oh my God I'm
like proud of myself it's a Wheel of
Time reference oh yeah no never got into
it wow
I I once said to carry should I read
Wheel of Time and she was like nah don't
bother
women pulling their ponytails and
flattening their skirts um the women in
it are all kind of an allegory for his
wife who he clearly hated their oh
really annoying Dolly like Dolly painted
his wife and like did some terrible
things kind of yeah
yeah one of those 14 books is riveting
and there are a lot of things that I
really love about them but they're how
is the show really boring chunks in
between I actually didn't watch it
I wonder if it's if it's a good
adaptation well it's interesting because
the first book is very much just Lord of
the Rings I've not seen any good
adaptations in a while I think it's oh
really
maybe soon so someone's gonna get it
right one day I think we just all kind
of hang in there I don't think so what's
the what's the vehicle that has two
wheels and you lean forward
oh it's a standing thing like a
basketball Segway oh what's that Mike
Jordan Segway
ston oh
nice penitence can I can I pay the cost
of can I tell you the best Segway fact
please yep do you the guy who invented
it went off a cliff
yes
there you go you're such an [__] I
thought the Segway was invented by um
Dean Cayman
the uh the uh the guy became his brother
uh if only
um no and all and all in all earnestness
there's an amazing documentary about him
trying to invent a solution to water
purification to essentially try to save
the world I know investing all of his
fortune
what what is yours this is how I'll do
it I'll put wheels on it and yeah he
fully acknowledges he's like the Segway
was not my shining hour but he he's like
a biotech uh guy primarily uh my
favorite was when Trey Parker and Matt
Stone bought one the instant they came
out and they immediately tried to jump
it off a ramp and blue and like
destroyed it in like the first 10
minutes I just imagine somebody pitching
a script that has like a Kevin Costner
but not Kevin Costner he's like staring
out over
some body of water going someday I'll
invent something it's going to purify
what no even better it'll draw folks
from around the world their fanny packs
they'll line up it'll get on these
things and that's how they'll see this
town that's how they'll see this town
it's mostly at this point it's mostly at
this point I think of Segways as airport
security uh yeah
really they use Segways on the Apple
security I just think of the whole blood
mole cup totally type yeah I don't know
Segway um Austin we mentioned trailers
and then you are going to bring
something up oh yeah we're still in the
middle of our Segway three hours ago
before too long too which is hilarious
so that's that's something yeah uh the
there was a lawsuit recently
um remember that movie yesterday about
the guy that wakes up in a world where
the Beatles never existed
so yeah so the
um the actress Anna De armas was in that
movie and they cut her she was like a
small subplot and they cut her character
completely but she was in a trailer and
some fans of hers sued them on the basis
of false advertising that the initial
teaser included her and it was in the
news just a few days ago like it's been
it's been kind of in limbo as they
decide if this is even a valid lawsuit
the second interesting legal case
regarding the movie yesterday which is
shocking that's amazing what was the
first one happy
did that have anything to do with the
music
Paul
I don't actually know about there being
another lawsuit awesome
it was to do with um
who actually wrote it or something
there was there was a disagreement about
who owned who wrote it because it wasn't
written by
um what's his name that said he did
um
but he he signed a contract saying that
he could take credit for it and I think
the writer there was a weird kind of
legal case around interesting he crossed
like anyway so yeah what happened with
the lawsuit well so it's I think it's
moving forward now because basically a
judge
uh like the the basis of the defense and
I'm obviously goes without saying I'm
not a lawyer I also didn't read it in
extreme depth but I read the sort of
like you know the the industry coverage
of it from like Hollywood Reporter and
variety and stuff where the long and
short of it is that the question the
defense posturing was trailers are as
much filmmaking as films it's an it's a
subset of the act of filmmaking so why
would it not be covered under Free
Speech plus obviously it's a creative
Endeavor in which things evolve and
change and the counter argument is uh we
don't hold advertising to free speech uh
uh rules the same way because false
advertising is a form of defrauding
people and and uh free speech is does
not extend to acts of fraud so therefore
there have to be standards of false
advertising and the judge came to the
conclusion we think that this lawsuit
should be able to play out and they're
case made on the basis that trailers are
principally advertising and not
principally works of creative arts which
I think I support that reasoning but it
also is a fascinating can of worms to
open because I always think back to like
BioShock Infinite as an example when
they did that initial E3 where there
were a bunch of stuff that had to be
subsequently taken out of the game or
refined or removed and then there's all
these people up in arms like that's
still that's deceptive and whatever and
it's like dude game design is iterative
and if you're forced to show something
too early it's gonna be different 100
Insomniac puzzle artists are terrified
yeah right well I think it can't apply
to games I just don't think it's
possible or well why not why I mean but
movies this was a movie they showed the
trailer before they had finished the cut
of the film they took her character out
because they got they got pause they got
negative feedback on her character
subplot undermining the kind of
emotional buy-in we had for the main
character because she represented this
like temptation of him with his
girlfriend and a lot and they decided to
cut that whole subplot out of the movie
because it wasn't testing well they
didn't need it and that's a reasonable
part to filmmaking that's a thing that
you do like you get feedback there's so
many great movie trailers that this
would mess up and also just like the
process I mean look at ROBLOX remember
that signature shot in Rogue one with
her facing down the Tie Fighter that's
not in the movie also herself
I think this was this was what made you
think of it was
sorry it's really good it's like but the
menu right the menu I enjoyed more
because the trailer implied it was movie
X and then it was movie Y and that was
fun or like um where they hide like with
like Marvel movies
yeah intentionally they will kind of
show that things can be surprises and
yeah you need to but I also understand
the complaint with like if you're using
annadaramus in your marketing and she
might have been the biggest name in that
movie I'm not sure who else is in it but
she's quite famous and then yeah sure
that that does seem like an exception to
kind of what we're talking about here
they're not hiding her to preserve the
film
practical as well like it means you
wouldn't be able to release a trailer
early generally a because of of creative
choices it would just sound like this
was that they kind of decided later oh
this isn't working but also just in
terms of production like movie trailers
are usually scored with music that's not
from the film because it's too early
they're usually using uh temporary
visual effects because it's too early in
game world like a trailer I look at a
trailer that we rendered X number of
months ago like any launch title any uh
sorry launch trailer for a game you
rendered that trailer months before it
all came out and every developer hates
them though because every developer
looks and sees all the things they fixed
since the trailer was was recorded yeah
exactly like all of this stuff like it
would it would absolutely change the
structure by which this like any kind of
creative entertainment stuff was
produced because you'd have to you'd
have to lock things way earlier and have
massive repercussions it struck me as a
fascinating thing because you don't want
to protect
especially the large you know like you
don't want laws that are automatically
going to bias in favor of like massive
corporate entities
um but it it does seem like
you are you you do want a world in which
if some if someone were to engage in
Mass forms of false advertising there
isn't precedent against holding them to
account in the legal system in a system
which heavily revolves around the
importance of legal precedent you would
you don't you don't want to create a
world where you know it's like it's hard
to call someone out and hold them
accountable for deliberately deceptive
false advertising but this does seem
like
um
it would have a lot of unintended
consequences the other direction like in
terms yeah let's not line our trailers
it's a solid I think I think we don't
agree with but yeah the process but you
do have in America there is a difference
I don't know if you guys would even be
aware of this but like free speech does
play into advertising in a way that it
doesn't elsewhere like your adverts can
compare products which which wasn't I
don't think it definitely wasn't the
case when I was a kid I still don't
think it's okay it's really it has to be
on Lucky five yeah well because you're
watching American advert it'll say this
is better than the competing brand and
they'll name them
Delta it's better than flying virgin
you'll see a trailer like that a
commercial like that
yeah I don't know the legalities of this
but but there is a there is a little bit
more Nuance to it than that which is why
most of the languages than other leading
Brands is what typically is the the
language that's used
um I think if there's ever you you can't
use something and again someone I would
love to be be in the comments to correct
me if you know this
disparagement so like libel or slander
you still can't do so you can't diminish
a specific product
by in in your advertising you can say
you can say a truthful thing about you
could say a truthful thing like a
product is better at doing this under
these tests yeah there's there's two
there's two specific examples yeah there
was especially in the 80s and 90s
the the the soda wars were really really
big and Coke and Pepsi and what they
could do is they could say
um in a taste test
Pepsi was chosen over Coke
ninety percent of the time or a hundred
percent or whatever that is a fact that
is not well it's not to be clear that is
the other bottle so in the UK yeah I
don't have I don't have horse in this
race it was a few yeah so the Pepsi
challenge was definitely yeah
Troy said 100
to be clear on this particular show that
is not a fact he was using an example
that is not verified
they could not show the Coke brand
because that if you use the amazing
ribbon device which is what that white
stripe across the can is called that is
that is trademarked so they they would
you would see in the commercials they
would always reveal that it was Pepsi
that they chose they wouldn't show Coke
however there is a commercial that coke
did
no sorry that Pepsi did
um where it's this you know 100 years in
the future 200 years in the future and
these these students I wish I could find
it
um maybe it's on the YouTube Somewhere
there's a group of students that are
being led through um through like kind
of the ruins of of old New York
essentially and they're like Professor
what is this they hold up a baseball I
was like oh this was a game where men
would hurl this ball at each other and
beat it with a stick and they would you
know cheer as a big celebration they go
through all these different things like
what is this what is this and he's
explaining what this was and pedestrian
products to the uni but to them it was
like this great wondrous thing and then
someone goes Professor what is this and
he holds up a Coke can and the professor
goes I have no idea we all drink Pepsi
it's like oh [__] to me it's a clever
solid commercial
that you know what's fascinating about
just as a quick little trivia what I
find interesting about the Pepsi
challenge was that whenever they did
those tests Pepsi always won but Coke
always outsold Pepsi anyway I hate the
taste of Pepsi it was because Pepsi
challenge was a sip test this was one of
the case studies in the Malcolm Gladwell
book blink where he said if you take a
tiny bit of Pepsi most people prefer it
because it's softer it's sweeter yeah
but if you're drinking an entire can
yeah exactly a Coke a Coke stands a
longevity test better and if most people
don't buy one sip's worth and I was like
that's an interesting show that like you
can you can construct a test to buy us a
certain result and win while while not
actually winning the the kind of larger
it's like the battle versus the War I
agree Pepsi would taste better initially
because you get slightly more of a cola
flavor from the first Sip and it's not
as bubbly whereas Coke like aggressive
but a whole can of Pepsi put that down
put that down right now I I don't really
do this anymore it's just a refreshing
cuddling though
I wasn't doing this guy I killed off
mine but yes geez that's violent
um murdered it was just awful what is
that are you are you are you sponsored
by them I am but I've been drinking it
for a very long time despite this was it
good what is it yeah um this is ag1 by
athletic greens
I think is what they make me say but um
this obviously but it is legit you do
quite like it yeah otherwise I wouldn't
be drinking it the sponsorship it's
basically just like a really good way to
get a bunch of nutrients all right you
mix up greens I've been looking at that
I've been thinking about that I love it
I think it's great yeah it also gives
you energy in a way that a coffee would
that um we mostly just is there green
tea in there
because like matcha dude if you want if
you want more caffeine than a cup of
coffee man
you do I love making an oat milk matcha
latte um
I don't actually know what matcha is
it's a green tea
just a type of green tea
powdered definitely a pun there Austin
you trying to work one out I know
there's a few things that I'm kind of
toying with but I know that one of the
two users about to shift into something
and I was yeah I was I was go ahead I
was gonna segue I was saying speaking of
post-apocalyptic wastelands
I was gonna do that same segue when he
said the ruins of old New York I was
gonna go but what about Boston
it sounds self-serving but it has to be
stated that I you know this is something
that I get to I've never
been a part of something where I've been
at the not at the Inception but
definitely in an embryonic phase of it
watched it it's like the originating
role on Broadway on a thing that's now
on a wild tour yeah but then I also get
to be in it too it's like oh and and now
we're I've just never been a partisan
like that but I they've been very very
kind very very gracious everyone at HBO
including Craig Mason uh and Neil
druckman of course have been very kind
of let me be kind of like come on you're
with us
um and so it's it's been very very kind
um but the the outpourings of of
messages that I received on Sunday was
just
I was I was so proud it's very um I I
can't I mean as a Brit it's very hard
for me to but it's really [__] good
man it's really funny Mike I'm not sure
if you have the right to watch it since
you haven't finished the second game
yeah but see I I watched I watched that
no I feel like
including I I played I played it to a
certain point because I wanted to
support friend and I stopped like no
joking I I just I do need to go back to
it though at some point but anyway it
was really [__] good that was an
amazing opening I thought it is I
thought the additions the it's really
what I love about it the thing I the
single choice that I really enjoyed was
how much use and I hope this carries on
as it goes on how much use they got out
of not having to be fixed with Joel's
perspective and the ways they can weave
in other stuff because they're not
having to do the game thing of keeping
you with the character I did have the
answer so that was really a lovely
expansion we're getting more context of
other characters and that's the thing
that I never expected to get because
like if we mentioned that we're talking
about the last
um
because the game is so much longer than
a TV show that I'm assuming is going to
end up being probably eight hours and
then the game is I guess it's 10 to 12
that much longer I expected that the
game would always have more context and
that the TV show would highlight
sort of like tinier pieces but it's
actually managing to expand and I was
like the gameplay out yeah exactly it
turns out five hours is upgrading your
gun yeah it's additive rather than
um well that's like if you think about
it so much of that experience is
wandering exploration being scared
dying and reloading there's a lot of
stuff that happens within gameplay that
it's kind of like the difference between
looking at a script I remember we shot
something one time on something else and
I looked at the first aid and it was
like oh eighth of a page will be in and
out of here and he goes famous eighth of
pages
exterior night Chicago City burns like
an eighth of a page can be George Lucas
once said it he was showing a script
from I think it was Phantom Menace and
it was like Darth Maul appears they
fight
[Music]
this is our month everybody this is what
we will be right here for this month so
in the same way you can condense and
again it's a great quote by David
Fincher all filmmaking is the
compression and expansion of time
um how much how much time are we
spending on this one moment versus how
quickly are we moving through it and to
be able to imagine how different the
world would be if no one had never seen
that quote
Jesus Christ
you got to watch something 99 the same
man generous Jesus watch following it's
like where's that filmmaker God he was
so good
following is so funny he's behind you
following you
um yeah
um but there's there's some really cool
things that that they do
the difference is you you let a fan in
charge and you let them run with it and
you do something that's fearless and
instead of trying to service fans you
service the story and that's what makes
it really really good
um they cast I love what Neil said he
goes we got lucky twice and it's so true
there's some things that you'll see in
episode two that are that are really
really great that that I look back and
go that's a really interesting point you
can't do it in a game but in a show you
can and there's a physicality that that
Pedro brings to Joel
um that is really really
um informing and I I am 100 comfortable
with this being the introduction to this
care these characters especially Joel
that people will have they may never
pick up a
a controller and they'll never make an
association with me to that character
but they will with Pedro and the most
important thing is is that they're going
to see that character well represented
that's all that I care about the same
thing goes with with Ellie I think I no
I'm not blowing smoke up your ass but
like the thing Austin said of like the
originating a role like a big musical
theater nerd and you can't you can't you
know watch any actor in a role in a big
you know Broadway show and not see The
Echoes of what they're kind of it's a
response to an earlier cast absolutely I
did feel I genuinely felt that watching
it of like that's that's a choice that's
a choice that reminds me of Troy that's
a that's a
moments there's plenty of Troy in it or
reactions to it like even if he's
swinging in the completely opposite yeah
like a conscious Choice it's still it's
still framed by that so I think yeah I
think it's it's interesting because I
think because it's so
because it's uh and I and because it's
because it does repeat so much of what's
in the game because it is very very on
point with a lot of its scenes there are
like you can do direct comparisons right
you can take a scene here's the Troy
version IGN posted a side by side and
you can yeah but you can see that and
you can see the choices and this is true
of of the entire cast it's just the way
in which they're kind of bouncing off of
it's very clear that the cast has played
the game
no so that here's here's what I think
that really is are they not it's a it's
a really good lesson as an actor
I when we were first shooting The Last
of Us
um part one when
we had been shooting maybe I don't know
we had three or four shoots and my I
think I've told the story before
um typically when I say that you can
count on the fact that I have who knows
um I would they would you know cut and I
would jump back behind video Village and
I would ask for playback so I could see
it and go got it okay I don't know the
way that I looked there uh and then Neil
came to me after one after we had shot
and he goes hey I need to do me a favor
I need you to no longer do that I'm like
okay well this is what I need and he
said no what you need to do is trust me
as a director and what I think the
difference is and this is why I go back
to Halo and go you visit the set and see
Pedro in video Village and you were like
[__] but Craig was like hey I
need you to not do that but also you
know like Craig was like I need you to
do that for roughly two days and then I
need to come over there and then we're
gonna create it and now we're doing one
to one uh like Norman Reedus you know he
he will go back and do that he's also I
think it's someone who's more seasoned
than someone who is is has better
control and distance I didn't and and
I'm at the point now where I can't not
direct myself if I go back and look
um so I think that that is it's not my
job my job is to be directed my job is
to come in prepared and understand and
have decisions that I'm going to make in
the moment but not to go pre-loaded yeah
be as helpful to the director as
possible not be the director absolutely
absolutely and so I look at what they
did and they said it's our job job to
have oversight and our job to frame this
in the way that we want it's not your
job to mimic something that's already
existed there's something I wanted to
come back to because I I realize there's
another kind of comparison that I can
make uh speaking of the the musical
theater
Cole Wilkinson
who was the actor who originated the
character Jean Valjean
um he did something similar he
originated the character in London
um and then you know obviously played
that I don't know how long he played
that for I mean well he played it again
like 10 years later he did he came back
he came back did a Revival I think he
was the only cast member that didn't
think they brought back to Jehovah
anybody else but in the movie they
brought him in and he played the priest
priest that Jean Valjean goes to and so
it's just this really kind of like tip
of the hat to the foundation and
literally the
the shoulders of the Giants that they
were standing on
um I would love to get his perspective
on it seems like
you know clearly this is a
it's it's based on Source material right
it's something that was adapted from The
Source material that's very very you
know it's it's a completely different
adaptation uh characters are different
moments are different timeline is
different than the book
um which is a brilliant book if you've
never read it
um my goal is to be able to read that
fully in French that would be my that'd
be my like one day you'll be able to
read just keep trying I'm I'm doing I'm
doing all right we have been so
supportive of our friend for like 10
minutes here yeah someone had to destroy
it
that's enough I can't take anymore you
only lost so long
but I I there's this there's speaking to
what you said Mike as far as like seeing
the Echoes of that there was this one
performance they did I think in New York
and maybe it may have been in London
where it was like a celebration of the
musical and they brought out all the
Jean valjeans and it was in London it
was in London
and you could see that it's like man the
evolution or maybe not the evolution but
the iteration at least upon that
character and how the once the movie
comes out it kind of changes the stage
show and there's some retconning that
goes into that but there's always some
stuff that we owe to the one who
originated this
um so maybe there's of course I assume
another similarity maybe here is is with
musicals obviously there's a
workshopping phase right so that
originator actor he's almost kind of a
co-author on a lot of levels right
they're involved in that process and I I
do Wonder with with um
how I know you know how I know game
development works and how I assume it
worked on loss of us there was also you
probably had more influence over that
performance than you would give yourself
credit for and the framing of that
performance in the game is probably very
reactive to the choices you made so even
if the cast of the TV show have never
seen your performance the script and the
choices that Neil's kind of carrying
over into the TV show would still have
been informed by conversations he had
with you choices that the two of you had
made together like that influence would
still be present I have I have
absolutely been spoiled uh by working in
games and
the I would I would encourage actors
regardless of whether you're a gamer or
not in some ways maybe even if you
aren't
um to work on a game
simply for the fact that it's it's kind
of the difference between being on a in
a play not because the way that it's
presented but it's like how long can you
live with this character and find
something new in it every night
um or every time you get in there it
also still maintain it because you're
going to go off and do other things it's
it's unlike anything else even seasons
of Television you're still there for
like two or three months or six months
or a year in the case of The Last of Us
which is the first was shot over a year
a month for the if you're doing the
seasons thing I mean I guess but I just
assumed that they would fake that
somehow no yeah yeah yeah like computers
is so much more practical I have a
friend that lives in Calgary and he sent
me a photo just like from walking around
the street and it's like there was a
huge section of of like the core of
Calgary that just straight up looked
like this post-apocalyptic like it was
so thoroughly dressed as a location that
it just looked like there had been an
apocalyptic event there you'll see they
built a neighborhood everything in there
on some level is practical yeah on some
level it shows it it feels like such a
grant the whole sequence of of driving
as the chaos is unleashing in the plane
crash and all that is they built that
street that like talk about like I'm I'm
very impressed by what's possible with
the use of the volume as a visual effect
medium but my God what a difference
being in a car that's actually moving
and there's extras running around and
there's pyrotechnics and I mean I'm sure
there's a ton of CG but it's integrated
into a shot that is overwhelmingly
practical and it's the Aging thunderway
Newton like that that was amazingly
impressive
Newton and looks exactly like uh to a
level that was confusing that's so funny
I was like dad's stand away Newton but
she's they had a hundred million dollar
dhbh exactly yeah the
without any disparagement against the
volume the joke was appalling I
apologize I do two we're just too slow
for it I do too many layers I do think
that the volume is going to be a little
bit kitschy and I think it I think it
will be I think does it does have a use
for for certain things not use the
volume right what's that The Last of Us
didn't use the volume right no no no no
no and our talking to our our DPS and
our camera Department most of them do
not want to work on that and most actors
that have worked on it do not want to
work on it doesn't add anything and it's
very very it's not true actors with
who've experienced it it's it's so
something that's in the FIFA there's
there's frame delay right now so it's
very jarring and the parallaxing that
happens
you might as well be
I you might as well be in like a mocap
stage because it's it's just oh I get
kind of where this is but you're also
looking at it from a very low res
because they can't generate that high
res of a of a version of it
um so you're also impressed upon me
something about it when you when you did
that thing that was in it you you
impressed upon me also that from the POV
of an actor it's kind of like you know
those chalk drawings people do where
it's it's like this amazing sense of
perspective and scale but if you look at
it from another angle you realize it's
stretched over like 30 feet and looks
completely bizarre it made it sound like
acting in the volume is like that from
the POV of the camera it's this amazing
proportionality and it moves and all
that's very cool but in for those in the
scene physically there it looks nothing
like that and it's very disorienting and
odd it forces your camera it forces your
camera lens it forces your camera angles
it forces your camera position it forces
the actors blocking it's very limiting
it's just great walking's the one that's
most visible I think to the Panzer I
watch those scenes and I can tell that
they only can move like five meters like
it feels is it significantly cheaper
than building a job no nothing sets
because like I feel like even those are
pretty obvious I would have thought like
you would opt to use the volume for the
stuff that like in Boba Fett was shot in
the desert versus going to a desert I
think it's I think it I don't know that
it's my my impression I defer to anybody
on this one but my impression is that
it's that it looks better than flat
green screen and it but it is
effectively a lateral replacement to
that it's not necessarily it still
requires the work like that's the thing
I'm not gonna like I having talked to
some directors who've worked with it
like you still have to do all the it's
not just I think the illusion is all
done in camera no it's not you you have
to then go and composite a background
it's not filmed I think people look at
it and they're like oh you just pointing
the camera and that's what you see it
like you still have to redo the
background like a green screen if we're
here then we know that this thing will
be visible that's true and so you're
like okay frame but you're not shooting
it you can do that with like a virtual
camera or if you can do with a lot of
other methodologies but like the last of
us they bought houses they're like we're
gonna buy your house yeah you're like
okay or they built up insulting when
someone comes up to you you're like your
house looks like it's been through it oh
the before I take the money by be
offended the befores and afters were
ridiculous like this was a great little
house or like we destroyed this house
um you'll see in episode two
um they're heading to the State House
and
I I thought I feel like that must be
such a I'm excited to see that happen
the person who gets to just go in and
just like [__] up a bunch of pre-board
houses that sounds very fun to me
they're like set dressings
yeah pretty much the level the level of
detail of people that were like
Cameron's gonna sweep past this or never
even see it it's gonna be so soft in the
background and it doesn't matter it's
like theme parks people do a lot of that
too in a way that I really love like 100
but I do believe that in games no more
where you you open a drawer sure and
there's like a whole set of props in
this drawer that you don't even have to
go in that room never mind I have a
narrative but the thing is is that in a
game you still have the opportunity to
explore that
you can make one brick and use it a
million times whereas in the real life
my as you know carries a prop maker so I
get to hear this like that you actually
have to make all of this [__] yeah we
got copy paste is amazing
that's true
that's the first wall we've ever had I I
I am I am stopping every time I talk I
shut down the conversation
is amazing
uh that's our show everybody thanks so
much
I'm a director come on well we can end
it here we're 50 minutes uh I don't mind
if we have to end a little bit early
after Mike ruin the conversation Jesus
oh stop it I'm looking forward next week
to whoever is going to be in the
director's chair on the uh on the four
of us uh casting of this well I was also
gonna say
um
why is this light just disappeared what
happened to you come on Bud there you go
um
you have to exactly talk about the loss
of us every week Troy but uh I'm gonna
be watching that every week and I'm very
excited about it it's very good um
little uh shout out to the I the podcast
also that uh the companion which as a
side note I didn't realize that
literally before the thing starts it
goes hey check out the podcast like it
front loads it as an ad which I was like
oh really they're doubling down but yeah
Troy hosting the the sort of Talking
Dead style let's unpack the episode I I
listened to it and I there were a lot of
things in there that
um were fascinating to hear them just
unpack but but in particular the thing I
was explaining this to Troy when we were
talking about it so forgive well enough
Troy you forgive the redundancy to
literally everyone else this is new uh
the um the thing that I thought that the
first episode communicated so
beautifully that is such contrast from
basically all other adaptations
um was that it somehow managed to walk
this line between
deep cut deeply faithful homage
well striking off in its own
demand like own Direction and with
confidence that it's going to introduce
new things or go deeper on things that
the game by necessity had to gloss over
like you mentioned the single point of
view so the fact that it's like it's
holding two things in its hands and it's
a way of communicating to the to the
Ardent fans we are not going to bungle
up this thing that you love but we are
not we are going to play with it and and
you can trust us in that and it felt
like it messaged that in its choices as
an episode and then listening to the
podcast thoroughly reaffirmed all that
because you could hear Craig's
a just Abiding Love for this game uh
that where all of this stems from and
Neil and also the the path of Neil's
prior failures to pursue like a movie
version and stuff and realizing like
you know it had to kind of come about
this way and just I was thoroughly
impressed the whole thing is very
exciting it was and that's another thing
is it's a very successful pilot like it
absolutely lays out its Wares and makes
you feel comfortable it because it
throws out a chair it makes you feel
very comfortable viewers
I will say that
um as Shameless as a plug as it sounds
it is a
us
wow second largest debut since Boardwalk
Empire
since Boardwalk um over a decade ago
damn isn't that wild so what's that set
what's it second to the house of the
house address how's the dragons is what
I thought
it was this record
I don't know it says the biggest second
largest debut since Boardwalk Empire how
do you categorize that because didn't
didn't rings of power say they had 20
million viewers
they said for HBO so it's still bigger
than House of dragons
unless that doesn't count as a debut No
it should absolutely it would yes new
show yeah
um to anyone who who hasn't listened to
it I I would kind of
uh reiterate or underscore some of the
stuff that that Austin said it is
it's just a worthy podcast but my
involvement notwithstanding it's an
incredible conversation to be a part of
to hear the process and that's that's
what I love about what we get to do is
it's not inside baseball like this is a
conversation about how the thing got
made why the why they made the choices
that they made and to me the context is
three different people three people from
disparate perspectives looking at the
same thing in a completely different way
and the conversation that evolves out of
that so the first episode is is good
it's a very similar to the pilot there's
a lot of onboarding and stuff setting up
but we I really feel like we found our
groove uh in the second and third
podcast because we just kind of like
loosened up a little bit more
um so if you if you did listen to it uh
um please continue to listen to it um
but if you haven't stick with it what do
you think in the description thank you
would you be cool if I listened to the
podcast instead of watching the show is
the show necessary to get the full value
or indeed like talking to play the game
don't watch the show like just just the
podcast
all right well that is it from us today
everybody I'm a lot of peace I'm a video
game right and that's me put the video
game director that's Austin winners
video and composer that's Rebecca he is
an actor and we will see you the only
non-video game specifically video game
this week yeah talking about real life
TV look at us baby real actor we'll see
you next week actor and podcast
he's a podcast host
foreign
[Music]